campaigning for the presidential race
has started in the philippines this week
and the main candidates to replace
outgoing president rodrigo duterte
include everyone from a boxing legend to
the son of the former dictator
and duterte's daughter is also running
for vice president it's going to be a
wild election season voters go to the
polls on may 9.
[Music]
six years from the last presidential
election cycle the three-month-long
campaign season has arrived the main
event is that race for president and
separately elected vice president
and while a world-renowned boxer is in
the mix the guy drawing the crowds of a
rock star is a politician
ferdinand marcos
if that name rings a bell it should
marcos is the son and namesake
of the philippines former dictator who
toppled a stable democratic government
in 1972 and imposed martial law
ferdinand jr is known as bong bong and
finds much support from younger people
born after ferdinand seniors
dictatorship
there is no filipino who's not in need
of help which is why we all need to come
together
standing at the side of ferdinand marcos
jr
another big name in filipino politics
sarah duterte a vice presidential
candidate who is the daughter of the
present president
often critical of her father while
backing marcos that kind of experience
we need
not only to sustain the growth and
development spurred by the current
administration
but also
to bring a more prosperous future
running a distant second in the race for
president is the current vice president
but also opposition leader lenny robredo
the only female candidate for president
after becoming one of rodrigo duterte's
staunchest critics
[Applause]
nothing can match our combined strengths
[Music]
so let's go and win this
if winning on physical strength mattered
former boxer manny pacquiao would be the
clear front-runner
a national sporting hero he is much
loved for coming from humble beginnings
to reign as world champion before
turning to politics to become a
congressman then senator
it's not my fight alone but the fight of
every filipino
the philippine economy will be a focus
in the campaign an economy hit hard by
the pandemic
corruption in public office is another
topic of interest and china's military
presence in the waters separating it and
the philippines
but those issues may well take a back
seat to personalities in the next three
months
and political dynasties
joining us is manila based journalist
j.c gatinga jc
i want you to explain what might be
difficult for many of us outside the
country to understand
the marcos name
can't possibly be a good association are
we missing something here
right great question melissa you know
what um
it has to be understood this way you
know ever since the marcosus were ousted
from power in 1986 they have not stopped
trying to reinstate themselves so this
has been a long coming
process of them trying to slowly find
their way back into the philippine scene
first through their hometown of ilocos
norte in the north of the country and
then slowly back into national politics
now why the name suddenly seems to be
you know not as pariah as it used to be
well it's a mixture of number one uh the
narrative has not been so well ingrained
among filipinos as we might have
expected that uh the facts that um
the ferdinand marcos senior uh the
progenitor the former dictator uh is
holds the guinness world record for the
greatest robbery of a government in the
world uh that's not very clear to many
filipinos apparently and then the
machinery of the marcos says uh
especially with the help of social media
they have just seeded their narrative uh
at first subtly but they're now uh very
very blatantly trying to whitewash their
family's reputation putting into
question facts such as the thousands of
atrocities during the marcos regime in
the 1970s and 80s as well as the fact
that they still have billions of pesos
worth of money from the government
covers that they have yet to return
supposedly
that's fascinating and then we have
sarah duterte as the sidekick to marcos
jr the daughter of rodrigo duterte what
does she bring in all this
well the duterte name remains very
popular and definitely what she brings
to marcos is a sense of legitimacy if we
recall in 2016 when marcos ran for vice
president he was running in tandem with
miriam defensor santiago she has since
passed away but she's a very credible
very highly respected politician and it
was a surprise
that she ran in partner with marcos but
then uh
many observers here say that it it
helped marcos very much in that it
really it changed many filipinos
perception of him that oh suddenly the
marcos are okay maybe the marcos weren't
as bad as uh they were framed up to be
also it did not help that in the
post-marcos years many politicians many
presidents turned out to be a
disappointment so that played into it as
well
and can we back up a bit because i'm
curious um duterte has operated like
such an autocrat
did he try to change the laws to hold on
to power and it just didn't work out or
what because it's almost it's surprising
there's a democratic process here i
think there were a lot of expectations
he tried to stay on
yes he did um in the earlier half of his
term he tried to initiate a change an
amendment to the constitution
under the guise of you know improving
the economic provisions but mostly
people were wary that it was to remove
the term limits to allow himself to run
for re-election that did not work out
because the senate stamped out the
effort early on uh so now we see his
daughter sarah duterte running for vice
president she had been expected to run
for president but given the alliance
with the marco says it didn't it
wouldn't have looked well if he or if
she started duterte and bongbong marcos
marcos jr both ran for president they
might have divided the support base uh
but yes uh duterte
did make attempts to try and stay longer
now we've been talking about the
fascinating personalities let's also
talk about the issues what do voters
want
right you know what filipinos for many
many filipinos it's really a matter of
daily survival which is why concepts
such as democracy and human rights and
and political freedoms often don't
figure in their list of concerns when
they head to the vote for them it's
about you know how to put food on the
table how can they make sure that if
anyone in the family gets sick that they
have the money they have access to uh
medicines and health care which for many
filipinos is a problem there is the
pandemic has shown that our health care
system is
nearly non-existent and very very uh
well it's not enough
so
uh because it is always it is mostly a
question of personal survival it also
makes it easier for people in power for
politicians to for the lack of a better
term buy their support from uh the
masses
jc kotinga thank you so much for joining
us as always